ant-man in the wasp source world premier
this week and once the film hasn't
received a global release yet several
sources from the screening have reported
what happens in both of the films post
credits scenes throughout this video I
will be discussing what happens in those
scenes but whilst this is predominantly
speculation there have been several
reliable sources that have reported the
same thing
there are huge potential spoilers here
for both ant-man and the wasp and
infinity war so it may be best to give
this video amiss if you want to go in
unspoiled with that out the way I'm
definition and this is my ending explain
video for ant-man and the wasp in the
post-credits scene Pym and Janet create
a smaller version of the quantum romp or
all that fits in the back of Louise's
van in order to retrieve quantum
particles Scott is sent into the
miniscule I mentioned where he begins
his mission once Scott is finished he
asks to be brought back through the
portal but things go awry when there is
no response
Scott is unable to return and become
stuck in the quantum realm and the final
shot of the scene cuts to the location
from which Scott set off where we
discover that Pym Janet and hope have
vanished there's a faint shimmer of dust
in the wind which signifies that
thanasis snap has ruled them all out of
existence this not only has huge
implications for the Pym family but it
also puts Scott in a predicament as he
is unable to leave the quantum realm the
second scene involves an amp playing a
drum kit and this seems to be a cup from
earlier trailers whilst this one is more
of a cool shot
it certainly doesn't deliver on the one
that came before it but it perhaps hints
at Scott's ability to control ants now
growing to a point that he is able to do
complex tasks and this could be a rescue
for him from the tiny dimension so what
do you think of the post-credits scene
of a man in the wasp do you think these
sources will be proven correct or is
there another rumor that you've heard
comment below and let me know and if you
enjoyed this video please like it and
subscribe to my channel to keep up to
date with all movie and Marvel news I
recently discussed the ending of Luke
Cage season 2 so make sure you check
that out next thanks for taking the time
to watch this video and I'll see you
next time
take care peace
[Music]